hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware review video and uh this is
what i got right here for you guys i'm
just going to shoot this video up before
i go out golfing today this is the
griffin elevator laptop stand and this
is it right here um i still have the box
that it came in hold on one second
uh this is actually the box here that it
came in and it uh if you watch the
unboxing video if you've seen this
already but it does show a few of the
the things about this laptop stand that
you might be interested in if you're
looking to buy it so here is uh the box
and actually on the box it shows it with
a macbook which is you know common a
common conception is that you can use
the the griffin elevator with a macbook
but actually you can also use this with
a pc laptop on in fact on uh on
griffin's website it does say you can
use this with any laptop mac or pc
and i've actually used this with both
the 15-inch sony vaio and the 17-inch hp
pavilion and they both sit well on this
and it doesn't have any problems
so let's just go over a little hardware
overview on top you can see here are
these uh these three i mean these two uh
grippy uh parts to it that are basically
uh what hold your laptop to the stand
and and helps it not slide off uh these
are really tacky they're made of rubber
and you know it's pretty well built it
makes sense
on the side here you can see this this
is made of brushed aluminum uh it's very
sturdy and if i go ahead and if i put my
17 inch laptop on this there will be a
little bit of that bend but the bend is
not really a big deal for me
uh and on the bottom there are two more
grips on each side you can see one here
and one here
and those are what grip your laptop
stand to the desk and help it not move
away
so i think that's that's pretty much all
you need for an elevator laptop stand
like this it's well built it's made of
three parts this part this part and this
part down underneath if you can see that
uh like i said before it's very strong
it was able to hold my 17 inch laptop
like i mentioned before so this is about
as far as it'll bend right here um and
that really isn't a big issue and it
actually does provide a pretty good
typing angle uh when it's when it's like
that the way it is right now is pretty
pretty good for any laptop anyone is
using a laptop another thing is that it
does provide minor cooling as you can
see there's a whole bit a lot of you
know a whole lot of air flowing around
under here if you do have your laptop on
top of the stand this is all the space
you have
for air flow so if you do have the fans
on the bottom of your laptop that's
where all the air is going to be
circulating and it does provide minor
cooling even without fans on the stand
itself so that's pretty cool uh that's a
good pro
uh the last thing is that the main point
of this is that it does elevate your
laptop
uh they do call the elevator because of
that it'll give you about seven six or
seven inches off the ground uh and the
best thing about this is this is that
you're gonna wanna use this if you're
using a laptop with say an external
mouse and keyboard and external monitor
because then then this will raise your
laptop up to the same height as your
monitor and you'll be able to use this
right next to your monitor next to each
other so you won't have you looking
down to your laptop and back up to the
monitor they'll be at the same level so
that's pretty cool and that's the main
point of this laptop stand so again you
can pick this up at griffin technology's
website thank you griffin for sending
this out to me and this will likely be a
part of my humongous giveaway that is
coming up
in honor of my summer vacation we'll see
how that goes um but you can pick this
up for 39.99 at the griffin technologies
website in the description and that is
basically it for you guys so i'm going
to give this an 8 out of 10 uh which is
pretty good for a hardware review from
mkbhd
again thank you for watching guys and
thank you for tuning in and uh see if
you want like this laptop stand you can
check out the link in the description
anyway thanks for watching this video
guys peace